in 17th century Europe terrible events
for affecting Jewish communities the 30
Years War the Cossack revolt and the
massacres of the Jewish people
they were also accused of blood libel or
the ritual murder of Christian children
they needed a redeemer a symbol of hope
so they turned back to their folklore
and to the golem
this mud and earth formed humanoid
creature turns up in many tales and not
only in Jewish but non Jewish stories
golems stories have survived over time
persisting an oral and written folklore
but it was during times of genocide and
war that the story of the golem holds
the most significance
I'm dr. Emily zarqa and this is monstre
in Jewish folklore there are three
reasons to create a golem as a way to
show one's mastery of the Kabbalah to
have a trustworthy and dependable
servant for labour or to provide
protection for the Jewish community
you've likely seen a golem even if you
didn't recognize it at the time he's
taken lots of different forms in recent
years inspiring characters in The
Simpsons Pokemon Dungeons & Dragons
Arthur and even The X Files
but Bolin's can be traced back to 6th
century Jewish culture he's old old as
dirt The Golem story most widely known
is the early 20th century version of the
Golem of Prague in it
rabbi lo asked the heavens how to stop
the persecution of his community and he
received an answer make a golem to do
this he seeks the help of two other
rabbis each born with power of one of
the four elements the rabbis represented
air fire and water
clay collected from the river served as
the earth element the rabbi's take the
clay and shape the form of a man
they each walk around the forum
counterclockwise seven times reciting
special letters the body begins to glow
and vapors rise from the form the Golem
opens his eyes now a living thing the
Golem of Prague is named Yosef and looks
human but cannot speak rabbi Lowe tells
the golem he was created to guard the
Jewish people from their enemies Yosef
has supernatural strength and can become
invisible with the help of a special
amulet he completes many tasks serving
as a watchman rescuing a kidnapped girl
and even summoning a dead woman The
Golem of Prague is only one version of
the golem others have existed for
thousands of years one could be brought
to life by a Jewish scholar usually a
rabbi and God's name is required in some
way to actually bring it to life you can
animate a golem by reciting the proper
letters of God's name placing God's name
into the golems mouth of fixing it to
the forehead or by placing the Hebrew
word for truth into the clay body
to understand why the golem is created
from dirt first we have to take a quick
look at another creation story one found
in the Torah the foundational text of
Judaism there it is said that God
created Adam the first man by forming
him from the dust of the earth and
breathing life into him Jewish scholars
developed the golem legend based on the
Adam creation story historians point to
a section of the Talmud where a rabbi
created an artificial man who is like
any other except he could not speak for
only God could give that power which
explains why all traditional variations
of the Golem are mute in later versions
the creature becomes dangerous are hard
to control because it gains power the
longer it is animated or it simply takes
direction too literally looking back to
the Golem of Prague perhaps the singular
most important character in these
stories even more so than the golem
himself is rabbi lo a real person and
noted leader of the Jewish community in
sixteenth-century interestingly lo
himself didn't believe in miracles
condemned magic and never wrote about
the golem in 1909 a manuscript
supposedly written by rabbi lo
son-in-law was discovered by Orthodox
rabbi youtl rosenberg although it's
generally agreed that this document
never existed he then published his
version of the Golem of Prague which
became one of the most important golem
legends the late 19th century was the
first time the golem became not just a
means of labor but a protector of the
Jewish people throughout the 19th
century there were multiple cases of
blood libel an anti-semitic accusation
that claims a Jewish person
ritualistically murdered a Christian
usually a child rabbi Rosenberg was all
too familiar with this there was a blood
libel case near Prague in 1899 as well
as organized violence against the Jewish
people in Russia at the turn of the 20th
century it makes sense that he would
portray the golem in his story as a
protector at a time when his people
really needed one in 1917 the golem
legends of the ghetto of Prague the next
popular text featuring rabbi Lowe was
published the Jewish author was part of
the community
forced to relocate to the interior of
Austria after the Russian invasion
although similar to Rosenberg version in
this story
rabbi Lowe is forced to destroy the
golem here named Joseph because he
becomes a danger to the entire city
nevertheless the story ends with the
golem waiting in the Attic of a
synagogue in Prague to be reawakened the
next time persecuted Jews need
protecting the increase in Jewish
migration throughout the 20th century
helps spread the golem story we've seen
it in movies ballet children's books and
comics but in each new version it has
continued to change form the original
goal of creating Ebola was to make
something more powerful than yourself in
most cases this was not done to oppress
or control anyone but to give the
creator and their community agency even
freedom what began as a way to
demonstrate mastery of a religious text
morphed into an unintended monster and
was later reclaimed as a protector
golems story is as malleable as the clay
from which it was formed hi Mazz from
fans Lord Socrates fancy-pants and I
want to tell you about our friends over
at America from scratch a PBS Digital
Studios show that's basically the best
civics class ever they ask what would
the u.s. look like if it was found today
tackling big questions like what if
there were no States or should be
colonized Mars
check out America from scratch in the
link in the description below and tell
them
Socrates sent you and to the gollum
gollum of the golem our mute did I say
Gollum again goal love ya ton of gold
ons